soaking up the adulation after one final
time on court
two decades of tennis greatness
celebrated in London's O2 arena with
Roger Federer overcome with emotions
tears of joy after pushing through the
pain barrier so the 41 year old could
head into retirement last night in the
way he knows best
showcasing the style and shots that wow
tennis fans for more than two decades
and ending a great sporting rivalry by
partnering with friend and Nemesis Rapha
Nadal playing for Europe against the
rest of the world
Federer's career isn't ending at the
scene of one of the 20 grand slams he
won but here in East London at a event
he helped to create the Laver cup the
scene of the final match in Federer's
illustrious career and fans have come
from all over the world to get the
chance to watch him playing for one
final time his style of play is so
elegant it's like he's dancing on the
court he never seems to be trying hard
but you know that he's got the heart of
a champion and he's always going to
fight for every point we're hoping she
can get a signature or a picture with
Roger that would be ideal
I think we'll probably all be on the
floor with sadness at the end of it all
the Troublesome right knee meant the
20th and last grand slam success came in
2018.
Federer has been a bystander as nadala
Nova Djokovic have overtaken his Hall of
slams
Ending by losing the doubles last night
with the Nadal will be a footnote in a
career when Federer spent more time
topping the rankings than any other man
even the greatest have to accept when
time is up playing the sport they love
Journey's End on the court but not in
the sport completely for the retired
Roger Federer
Rob Harris Sky News Greenwich